we are currently about 13 days since
lockdown and it has been over probably
20 days since I've been able to train in
jujitsu because all of the gyms closed
before the lockdown even happen I've
been getting a little stir-crazy I've
been doing some solo drills but it
hasn't really been that effective and
other than me trying to get Jenna to
fight me since Jenna doesn't really want
to participate I got something it is in
this box I need your help I'm putting
this Jen but before I do I'm asking you
guys one simple question what is the
craziest and weirdest and strangest
thing that you guys have purchased or
need to purchase while in quarantine you
know I'm gonna like this creep it in my
Amazon I was trying to make a return for
you we never strike prepared people here
we go
here it is my very own grappling dummy
okay where's the chainsaw oh wait oh
this is going to be to read it please
don't fight back yeah that's great
that's gonna hurt your hand
so now that we have this board in the
house that he's gonna house quote these
old rocks that he didn't this is weird I
feel uncomfortable
[Music]
so they don't have to order whose monkey
I can sing it to him it's really
whatever whatever cuz don't know it
maybe we'll just have to be practicing a
little dogies for the time being until I
get you one your own size
hi Maddy do you think that I'm crazy all
right well I'm gonna hook up some girls
now I just finished getting his video
and I realized there's only three
minutes so that I would just kind of hop
back on here and just say hi see how you
guys are doing I'm sure some of you guys
might be really confused because you
probably had no idea that I had been
training jiu-jitsu for the past two
years so last month I wrote a little
blog post just talking about it because
it means so much to me and over the past
several years that has helped me get
through a lot of really tough times and
now that something that has sort of been
I guess my therapy is now not something
that I can do or a lot of us can do and
I know for a lot of people that you just
sue is their outlet it's become
something that you need to do for
yourself so I've just been trying to
find some ways to still stay active and
I'm feeling like such a hypocrite
because at the beginning of this whole
quarantine thing I told myself I told
you guys the most important thing to do
was to work out everyday stay active and
I've been struggling really very hard
doing that and I've been watching like
other people's videos of them talking
about all the incredible things that
they're doing during quarantine creating
art creating music creating YouTube
videos and I wanted that to be me and
then I just kind of it really has it and
I think what's important is that no
matter of what you guys are doing right
now I think the key thing is just
surviving and getting through it and
kind of adapting to this new way of life
because I don't think that life is ever
gonna be the same like nothing after
this will be the way that it was before
and I think coming to terms with that
and accepting it I'm not there yet I
don't think a lot of us are there yet so
I think just working through that and
processing and trying to figure out what
the new normal is is I think something
that we're all kind of working through
together so I really do want to hear
from you guys like what are you doing to
keep yourself busy to keep active to
keep yourself as sane as possible
because to go from one lifestyle to a
completely other overnight is very
challenging so whatever you're feeling
it's completely normal and I've really
been trying to just create content that
is keeping me entertained
that is also keeping you guys
entertained because the one thing that I
didn't want to do was to keep creating I
didn't even want to make any videos when
this all started and it was because of
you guys who tweeted me when I asked
what I should do and what youtubers
should do you guys had to keep creating
and keep being that sort of normal
consistent thing that you enjoyed
watching before all of this started and
that's what I've been trying to do it's
been giving me a little bit of normalcy
and I've also been spending so much time
playing Animal Crossing I hope that you
guys have been enjoying the gameplay
I've had a lot of fun making them and
even editing them has been really fun
it's been such a long time since I did
that and I feel like when I started my
gaming channel many many years ago I'm
much faster I don't know so it's taking
way less time to edit these videos than
it did back in the day I also much
faster computers that also can help
another thing this is every time I call
I think it's the end another thing
speaking of editing the final cuts and
logic is free for 90 days so if you guys
have ever wanted to learn final cut you
used to be a 30-day free trial but now
Apple is giving 90 day free trials so go
check it out I am such a huge fan of
final cut
the final cut tutorial if you are
incredibly bored and want to try to
learn final cut and have me teach you
well that's it I just wanted to kind of
end this video and see how you guys are
doing and give you an update on what's
happening over here because I feel like
a lot of times people think that
everything is perfect in people's lives
that they watch online and it's you know
it's all curated the stuff that we post
on Instagram
at some point I think we lose a lot of
reality and the sense of reality because
if we're posting fun stuff all the time
you think that person is fine nothing is
wrong they're great so just keep in mind
that what you're feeling probably
everyone's feeling that way no matter
what sort of face or front that they're
putting on so that being said I look
forward to being able to train again
hopefully sometime soon but it is really
incredibly important that we try to stay
healthy and we stay away from people as
hard as it might be just stay inside and
may I recommend you have the Nintendo
switch get Animal Crossing it will fill
your days
[Music]
[Applause]